- [Narrator] The Federal Reserve
keeps raising interest
rates to fight inflation.
Today, it's at nearly 4%.
- And we continue to anticipate
that ongoing increases
will be appropriate.
- [Narrator] But what
about the interest rates
that make you money like
on your savings account?
Right now, the average
savings account pays
less than a quarter of a percent
but some savings accounts are going
up just as fast as the Fed's.
- You know a lot of what you experience
with what's happened with savings rates
really depends on where you're looking.
- [Narrator] Here's why most
savings accounts are lagging
behind the Fed's rising
rates and which ones aren't.
Let's start with why a bank
pays you interest in the first place.
It's because, well, they need your money.
Banks use the deposits
people keep with them
to fund loans like for
cars or credit cards
and they profit off of that interest.
Basically, they need these
deposits in order to make money,
which is why they entice
you with savings rates.
- The savings rate that a
particular bank is paying
is a reflection of their
desire for additional deposits
or their attempt to retain
the deposits that they have.
That's it.
- [Narrator] Greg
McBride works at Bankrate
which compiles this data
on savings accounts.
- We survey financial institutions
for rate and fee information
on a wide range of
consumer banking products
- [Narrator] And there is a wide range
all in competition to keep your money.
A traditional savings account
with your regular bank
isn't the only safe place.
There's also online savings
accounts, which traditionally,
pay more interest than your
local brick and mortar bank.
Then there's CDs or
certificates of deposits.
Basically, the bank will
pay more in interest,
but only if you keep that money with them
for a set amount of time.
It's similar to a
government treasury bond.
You earn more interest,
but your money is tied up
not readily accessible like
these savings accounts.
But with all these choices,
if the rate rises on one,
it usually pressures the
others to rise too, usually.
- If banks want to retain deposits,
they've gotta keep pace with
what government bonds are yielding.
Otherwise, savers will take their money
out of the bank and put
it in government bonds.
- [Narrator] Those government bonds
are yielding high Interest Rates though.
They are keeping up with
the fed's rising rates.
So, why aren't these savings accounts?
The answer lies in this chart.
The amount of money currently
held as deposits at banks.
You can see this huge spike here in 2020,
where people stopped spending,
started saving and
received stimulus checks.
The banks were flush with
deposits and they still are.
Experts like Greg say
not only do big banks
not need to attract deposits,
but also see rising
rates as an opportunity.
- Well interest Rates were
at record lows for years.
And so, what happened was
that squeezed bank interest margins.
- [Narrator] Banks don't
wanna pay more in interest
than they're bringing in, right.
For a long time, even before the pandemic,
the Feds kept interest rates low
meaning the rate they profited from
like car loans was also low.
Now that the fed's rate is going up,
meaning these rates are too,
they're not going to
increase the savings rate
unless they really have to.
And overall banks have so
many deposits right now,
they don't.
- A lot of the bigger banks in particular
they're sitting on a mountain of deposits.
They have more deposits than
they know what to do with.
So the last thing they're gonna do
is raise cost of that.
- [Narrator] So who is
paying a competitive rate?
Online accounts,
often called high yield savings accounts
are offering savings
rates as high as 3.5%.
- Banks that are eager for deposits,
that have a growing loan operation
and need to feed that machine
by bringing in more deposits,
they will pay increasingly
competitive rates.
- These types of accounts
are still FDIC protected like any bank.
You just have to transfer money
in and out of them online,
which could take a few days
as opposed to being able to make
a same day withdrawal in person.
- If you're not taking any risk,
would you rather earn 3 1/2%
or would you rather earn 0.01%?
I mean, that's a slam dunk. That's easy.
- [Narrator] So why isn't
your savings account
going up with the Fed's rising rates?
It could be because you have
your money in the wrong place.
(cheerful music)